how does the batman's explosive finale
stack up to batman and robin's pun
filled finale does batman vs superman
dawn of justice wear the kryptonite
crown when it comes to bat finales holy
climaxes batman
there aren't a whole lot of people out
there who would argue that joel
schumacher's 1997 film batman and robin
was a masterpiece the bloated flashy
sequel to the 1995 hit batman forever
dialed the silliness way up to an
unprecedented degree while the
television series from 1966 starring
adam west was also very goofy the humor
was intentional none of the jokes in
batman and robin land and the rest of it
is basically an amusement park stunt
show the climax of the film is no
different with gotham city frozen it's
up to batman robin and batgirl to save
the day while that isn't a terrible
premise for a fun and campy adventure
film it's so noisy and cluttered that
you can't appreciate any of the heroics
that we're supposed to find so exciting
on top of that the characters are so
devoid of charisma and depth that we
can't even force ourselves to care what
happens to them with a few changes in
the dialogue casting and tone this could
have been a loving big budget tribute to
the 1966 series instead it comes across
as a cynical toy commercial you're about
to become compost
after the dark and twisted batman
returns the franchise took a notably
more family-friendly approach with its
next installment batman forever the film
is big bold and incredibly uneven while
it contains some staggering imagery
kinetic cinematography and a fun
performance from jim carrey is the
riddler there isn't much of a story
happening the action set pieces are
linked together by scenes that hint at
interesting ideas and possibilities that
never get a chance to develop nice bike
hang out at a lot of biker bars bruce
bruce coming to terms with his own rage
over the murder of his parents in order
to help the grieving dick grayson cope
with his own tragedy could have led to a
thrilling conclusion where the heroes
finally suit up and work together
unfortunately the conflict between them
is limited to a few arguments with no
substance so as huge and visually
riveting as batman and robin facing off
against the riddler in two-face may be
on a purely cinematic level the lack of
any real emotional resonance leaves this
otherwise mostly entertaining film
feeling hollow
tim burton's second film about the dark
knight batman returns has all the
ingredients of a masterpiece for one
thing it features an incredible cast
playing iconic characters also burton
had just come off a major creative
victory with the stunning and
sentimental modern fairy tale edward
scissorhands suggesting his next project
would be his magnum opus
there are elements of genius here but
just like batman forever the story
linking them together is paper thin the
tragedy of oswald cobblepot seeking
revenge on a city that rejected him
could have been the perfect motivation
for a truly maniacal villain bruce and
selena's doomed romance could have set
up one of the all-time greatest love
stories but none of it leads to anything
hey stud i thought we had something
together
we do
most of the character motivations are as
murky as sewer water making it difficult
to understand why anything happening
even matters this makes it virtually
impossible to get invested in the film's
climax
all the primary players are together but
we're not quite sure what brought them
there still the penguin's death is truly
unsettling as is selena's even stranger
murder of max shrek if nothing else you
remember what happens even if you're not
sure why they happen
some people may consider this a little
high for the original batman feature
film after all many fans consider it a
borderline parody of the character
however the film is closer to the style
and substance of the comics of the time
than many fans might like to admit and
at least the tone is consistent
throughout also unlike some earlier
entries on this list the humor is
intentional and actually funny listen to
these riddles tell me if you interpret
them as i do
one what has yellow skin and rights a
ballpoint banana right the movie is
almost the greatest hits of the
television series the penguin riddler
joker and catwoman have joined forces
for world domination through a series of
fiendish plans this unholy alliance gets
close to accomplishing their dastardly
goals but batman and robin never give up
with lots of comedy exciting plot twists
and a splash of romance this film
succeeds in delivering a crowd-pleasing
experience the finale even features an
all-out battle royale aboard a submarine
with batman and robin clocking henchmen
left and right sending them into the sea
at one point batman takes on a series of
thugs while cradling a cat in one arm
before sending it off in a tiny
inflatable raft it's bright colorful
intentionally silly and the ending does
not disappoint
after the brilliant heights achieved in
2008's the dark knight there was no way
christopher nolan was going to top
himself that being said dark knight
rises makes a valiant attempt at doing
just that its scale is bigger the tone
is relentless and vain though not as
charismatic a character as the joker is
a complex adversary capable of pushing
batman to the very brink the problem
lies in the decision to make this a
concluding chapter of a trilogy rather
than the batman's next adventure after
setting up this fascinating universe in
the previous installments we were denied
the chance to see new interpretations of
other fan favorite characters this
batman story was ending just as it began
this led to an overly complex and
confusing plot that had to both
establish new characters and tie them
into batman's origin instead of standing
on their own while the film is still
epic in scope and packed with phenomenal
action sequences story inconsistencies
and sudden revelations weigh the whole
thing down still the image of batman
possibly flying off to his death to save
the city is powerful and the suggestion
that john blake aka robin is going to
take up his mantle allows the world to
live in the imaginations of fans
everywhere
the first cinematic pairing of batman
and superman may not have been what
everyone expected but it did result in
some pretty great moments that almost
outshine the film's weaknesses the
ending is a prime example of all the
things that do and do not work in the
film for instance the confusing plot
orchestrated by lex luthor to have
batman and superman fight to the death
is conveniently resolved when superman
inadvertently informs batman that their
mothers share the same name
also superman's sacrifice is both
overblown and unnecessary we just met
this superman in the previous film and
were already being asked to mourn his
death when we had very little time to
get to know him it's treated like an
enormously tragic moment but it comes
practically out of nowhere conversely
the inclusion of wonder woman gives us
the chill-inducing moment where we
finally get to see dc's trinity stand
together just like the rest of the film
many of the climax's details are muddled
and strange but the simple excitement of
having three classic heroes joining
forces to defeat a common enemy is
absolutely thrilling
matt reeves attempt to reconnect batman
to his noir detective roots has
appropriately enough a dark ending that
feels like something out of daschle
hammett or raymond chandler gotham has
been largely destroyed the result of
riddler's plan to detonate bombs near
the sea walls surrounding the city
sending rushing waters through the
streets and nearly killing hundreds of
citizens gathered at a local arena
thankfully batman and catwoman were
there to help out battling riddler
wannabes attempting to anonymously
amplify the supervillain's destructive
efforts although they save characters
like bella rayal and the late mayor
mitchell's son anybody you can
reasonably call a good guy in this film
limps into the shadows at the end
licking their wounds
catwoman realizing batman is forever
linked with gotham leaves the city bruce
wayne newly burdened by realizations
about his beloved parents that make his
mission of vengeance far more muddled
says in voiceover the city is angry
scared like me with many of gotham's
most powerful men on both sides now dead
opportunities seem to be opening up for
folks like the penguin
ridler now in prison has a next-door
neighbor at arkham who speaks of clowns
and a comeback story if nothing else the
end of the batman seems to be setting up
one heck of a sequel
the dark knight is probably considered
the best film on this list it picked up
the reigns of batman begins and built an
even bigger and menacing world than
before of course heath ledger's
performance as a joker was instantly
legendary and remains a major
contributing factor to the film's
success but the dark knight is still an
epic by any and every measure which is
why the end is such a letdown
not to say that it's bad by any means
it's just that the rest of the film to
this point has been so dynamic and
spectacular that the idea of waiting to
see if criminals on a boat will choose
to destroy another boat doesn't measure
up
also we've seen batman and the joker
face off on top of a building before and
it was much more emotionally gratifying
in 1989. yes harvey dent's turn to evil
following the murder of rachel dawes is
tragic and the decision to let batman
take the rap for his crimes perfectly
demonstrates what makes him a great hero
but his defeat of the joker falls a
little flat this is an
oversimplification of the ending of
course but one can't help but wonder
what happened to the amazing momentum
built up in the first two acts
the 1989 release of tim burton's batman
was the introduction to the concept of a
dark batman for many audiences while
comic book readers had been well aware
of the character's many gothic exploits
your average moviegoer probably just
knew the adam west batman up to that
point the film is totally inconsistent
with a serviceable if underwhelming plot
but it's all elevated by its ending
while the rest of the film is certainly
entertaining and still worth a re-watch
today it's the emotional impact of the
ending that allows the movie to stand
tall as still being one of the very best
cinematic outings for the caped crusader
you killed my parents
what oh
what are you talking about
i made you
you made me first
when it's revealed that the joker was
the man who gunned down his parents
batman pursues the mad clown through
gotham city and to the top of a church
from here on out batman's mission isn't
just about protecting the city he's out
for revenge against the shadowy backdrop
of the towering cathedral joker tries
everything to prevent batman from
seeking justice but it is ultimately
futile despite the fact that this
confrontation and the motivations behind
it doesn't exactly honor the comics all
is forgiven because the final moments
are so emotionally and narratively
satisfying
batman begins is so different from any
of the films that came before that it's
hard to imagine it was released a mere
eight years after batman and robin the
next two films in this trilogy would
take this grounded reality even further
to the point that they almost ceased to
be batman movies and become movies that
happen to feature batman begins however
is still holding on to some of the more
outrageous elements of batman's comic
book origins the third act with
scarecrow's nightmare toxin causing
horrific hallucinations and the city of
gotham tearing itself apart plays out
like something right out of the pages of
a comic book there are innocent citizens
losing their minds and a horse blowing
flames from its nose it is absolute
chaos and batman is using everything he
has to stop it from getting worse
the most rewarding moment though has to
be batman's final showdown with raz al
ghul
the entire film sees bruce trying to
prove that murder isn't justice so when
he tells roz
i won't kill you
but i don't have to save you it's a
brilliant moment that makes you want to
stand up and cheer
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite batman movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you